[Music]
and you
you see that
you also don't have the cross-language
@bz Ribot boom so let's hit that detail
cross while check is it on starting to
take his weight off to give in to none
then you throw it back in Joe Don go one
to be bold backwards this way
oh just work on that detail you see that
you see that a lot on you guys you're
bringing the hang around you you want
the same uppercut as yesterday
you're just to each another rotation
here comes the uppercut but my body's
not gonna stay still my body so I keep
forth
okay slow like smooth don't let the arm
[Music]
swear to him
he's throw up leave it there turn turn
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm not standing the outside and lobbing
grenades my body is the time
[Music]
you're moving your arm around put it on
top of your head for your body pop your
head leave it there you're not attacking
her math
[Music]
bring your scapula a little more troodon
in there before done there you go
mass your head tilted you crown is the
top of the head top looking in so you
don't dip your chin
[Music]
displaces mass don't just use your hand
more tack his body with your body body
oh there you go
body phone that's it
[Music]